so I'm going to talk to you a little bit
today about learning healthy models for
healthcare so for some background I did
a PhD in computer science at MIT so
that's kind of my my training and during
my PhD I spent a lot of time sitting in
hospitals in the Boston area and looking
how doctors practice and trying to make
some sort of robust understanding of how
machine learning can improve healthcare
in different ways I almost didn't make
it here because for those of you who
have not been to Toronto in the major
airport there Pearson the International
Airport
you have to clear immigration u.s.
immigration on the Canada side on the
Pearson side and there were all of the
the nice you know immigration booths and
there were zero officers at that booth
for two hours and when we asked you
there's like a mob of every passengers
like what's going on they said well
they're at the border and we were like
this is a border like what-what border
are you talking about they're like no
the border so apparently a lot of a lot
of our you know screening officials are
at the border you know so I'm going to
start today out with asking you like pop
quiz right because we don't have coffee
in here so I have you at your weakest so
what we usually consider to be evidence
in medicine right and these are things
that I learned during my PhD because I'm
not a medical doctor
right so the doctors on my thesis
committee forced me to learn these
things so randomized control trials are
what we believe are the evidence that
should be used for determining whether a
treatment is effective right and if
you're thinking from the machine
learning or algorithm perspective you
might think well you know these are sort
of the gold standard so maybe we should
be optimizing for something like this
so the first pop quiz is what percentage
of treatments that are currently used in
hospitals today do you think are based
on an RCT 3% Cynthia god you're killing
me
it's ten to twenty first that it's not
that bad it's not that bad all right
so the follow-up to this the follow-up
to this is and these are medical
journals right this is no no computer
scientist was harmed in the making of
these numbers let's take something that
did have an RCT so for asthma which is
very common right I think it's one in
eight American adults that have it now
they did randomized control trials so
they put up a bunch of ads they had
people come in they looked at inclusion
exclusion criteria and they tried a
bunch of different treatments and there
is now a set of guidelines that we all
agree is the gold standard for treating
people with asthma so the question is
what proportion of people today who are
being treated would have qualified to be
included in those RCTs it's something
lower right so unfortunately in this
case only 6% of asthmatics would have
been included would have qualified to be
included so 94% of people are currently
treated are part of the exclusion
criteria they wouldn't have been allowed
to participate so this should worry you
right because the I love the name of
this paper it's the external validity of
our CTS to whom to these results apply
we don't actually know right so starting
from that sadness why is this important
it's important because human treatment
pathways as currently practiced right
not this is not in an RCT setting now
this is George herp sack a few years ago
somehow commenced a bunch of people to
pool their sources of medication claims
together so this would be saying for
example I'm diabetic and I get
medication a and then that's not working
so well so then I get medication B and
then I get medication X but maybe
somebody else gets medication X and
stays on that for a while gets Y gets a
gets B gets C right so that's your
pathway and so in this data set of 250
million patients across four countries
and eleven sources how many people would
you assume what percentage of people
would you assume would have a completely
unique treatment pathway meaning no
other patient ever in this data set had
the
same trajectory of medications my
assumption was it would be small right
it's not as small as you would like it
to be it's ten percent of diabetics it's
11 percent of people with depression and
it's 24 percent of people with
hypertension which means if you ask the
question in an underlying population of
250 million patients based on my
three-year treatment pathway what
patients are similar to me who can I
learn from the answer for a quarter of
people with hypertension is nobody you
have 0 nearest neighbors so if we're
starting from there knowing that our CTS
don't apply to everybody right by design
and also empirically human treatment
pathways are relatively unique the
question is maybe there's an opportunity
right so this is why there is a machine
learning for health sort of field
because we think maybe we could use data
to understand what's healthy what works
for different populations what are
optimal treatments and lots of things
could be medical data right it doesn't
just have to be what we traditionally
think of as medical records the ways
that you interact with your environment
could be medical data because it's about
how you are healthy so but the problem
with working with with medical data with
all data is that bias is already part of
the landscape and importantly for
machine learning and health we know it's
part of the clinical landscape there are
many robust studies that have
demonstrated that biases and society are
reflected in the biases and your health
care data this is a well-known thing and
so the question is how do we interact
machine learning with healthcare in a
way that respects fairness and so the
ways that we've been talking about this
within this the sort of sub community
are three ways right so there's
inequality of access right and so this
is if you're looking at data right do
two people get access to the same
resources can Mary Annie and see the
same category of doctors there's an
equality of treatment maybe Mary Ann Ian
can see the same kind of doctors but
Mary gets different treatments than Ian
does and finally there's an equality of
outcome so this would be Marian Ian see
the same kinds of doctors and get the
same kinds of treatments but they don't
work well for Ian for example because of
existing social determinants
so much of what I've looked at and this
is you know a very new stuff right so I
don't think there's a there is not a ton
of work in this field right now I think
it's growing has to do with differences
in treatment and so for example we know
that patient populations have treatments
treatment differences by all of the
variables we would not want them to have
treatment differences so race sex
socioeconomic status if you can choose
something you think that there is a bias
enchance us are your data will reflect
that and so the question is how do we
ensure that learning and prediction is
fair across those groups where you want
it to be fair so my group in Toronto
focuses on creating actionable insights
in human health and so there's three
broad categories of research that I
target today I'm going to talk very
briefly about two papers that we've
published in the machine learning how
fairness sort of subspace and then I'm
going to bring up sort of broader future
questions so the first is the very first
thing that we looked at during my PhD a
long time ago this is eons ago now so
the question is it was the the first
time that I had worked with real
hospital data so about 40,000 patients
in the mimic three data set from Beth
Israel Deaconess Medical Center I see
use can we use the data about an
individual a patient to predict whether
they're going to die in the next 24
hours so this is important because
doctors often have to do back hand or
back envelope calculations about acuity
how sick do I think this patient is
there's no actual data nobody actually
like writes those down somewhere in the
EHR and so we're using mortality as a
proxy for acuity and instead of just
using labs and vitals this numerical
information that is commonly used we
chose in this early work to use the
clinical notes we chose to do that
because when I was rounding with doctors
I noticed that they did not often look
at the labs and vitals with the same
frequency that they look at their notes
and so we use a standard I would say
it's now one of the first things people
do to process clinical notes method
called Lda we can talk more about that
during a break if you're interested but
it's very standard I think in many
communities now to model half-a-million
notes on about
thousand patients and then we use those
topics to predict mortality and we
compare them to the standard sort of
static measures that were used at the
time to predict mortality and what we
found is is what you might imagine which
is that the standard sort of baseline
models that were used by doctors right
so these would be things like
comorbidity scores acuity scores gender
what you're admitting diagnosis was
that's the blue line and it's
performance where higher is better does
worse and worse as you spend more time
in the hospital which makes sense they
go stale right you score somebody when
they come in and now it's not relevant
24 hours later but the topics which are
in red do better and better over time
because you're accumulating power right
you're accumulating information about an
individual and when you combine them in
green that does best of all so this is
all very nice it's it's like a pretty
result so that was five years ago now
and just last year at the end of last
year a doctor poked me and said did you
ever check to see how well your models
do across different groups and I said
haha I included those those variables in
my models so of course it's fair but
obviously it's not so just this year in
the AMA Journal of ethics we have a
follow-up piece that we published
showing that in fact the state of the
art models and mine in particular the
one that I trained five years ago right
that we had this initial work on they're
not fair
if you define fairness as having equal
accuracy between different groups and so
in particular it's not fair across
insurance type ethnicity and gender and
so I think the the important thing to
take away or that I took away from this
experience is that including race or
insurance or gender whatever variable
you've included which I would say as the
machine learning community we've been
conditioned to think of as being the
thing to do you include those things in
your model and you're good to go ship it
it's really not enough because if you
include genomics data as an input
modality that doesn't give you the same
as including race as a variable all of
the different interactions that are
going to occur because race is a social
category it's not a biological truth and
I think within the machine learning
immunity we don't really think of it
that way right now you include this data
in your model and therefore you think
that it must be robust but that's not
actually true and so briefly the second
thing I want to cover is issues of trust
and so there was this nice paper a year
ago in Ontario that looked at whether
recent immigrants so the thing to keep
in mind here is yes but no it's
self-reported race so as correctly as
race yeah so we're using the
self-reported race it's just it's not
enough no no the so the we use the
variable and the variable is correctly
assigned in the model as an input but
using the variable even if it's correct
even in your model is not enough if
you're optimizing a you see on a global
population we didn't have you know
optimize a subject to constraints of
these right and most of us don't
right when we train them Otto we don't
say and now make sure that insurance
types do equally well so this is the
issue even when your data is correct
even when it's self-reported even when
you include it it's not enough so people
so there are more notes for certain
kinds of patients the issue with looking
at note length is specifically in the
ICU there's high turnover and if you're
there longer so when we looked at
differences in the number of notes by
length of stay there wasn't a
statistically significant difference you
do often get longer notes in a very
specific case that I'll cover later
so the second part of this is so in
Ontario in Canada we have a single-payer
system right it's the provinces in
Canada are much more independent than
states in the US
right so they have significantly more
jurisdiction over what happens within a
province there's sort of a weaker
federal government for better or worse
so in Ontario a study was done last year
where they looked at immigrants because
there's a there's a one big database
that just says you know who is an
immigrant and who isn't who's a recent
immigrant and they looked at end-of-life
care and so something to keep in mind is
end-of-life care is a contentious topic
okay people are dying they often want to
be as comfortable as possible when
they're dying it is a very sensitive and
emotionally loaded time for everybody
and so what they looked at was
aggressive end-of-life care this means
in your final days did you get
aggressive treatments that did not
change the outcome you were dying and
yet you spent your final day using
aggressive mechanical ventilation and
vasopressors
right so this is the definition that
they used and they found that
specifically non northern European North
Western European immigrants to Ontario
got significantly more aggressive
end-of-life care than people from
northern and western European countries
and then long-standing residents in
Canada and so they they're very careful
in the study I should say you should you
should read this to like caveat
everything they say I think we don't
know what's going on we don't know why
we're not saying doctors are bad etc etc
and so we tried replicating this in the
mimic data set because it's open right
and so it's something that we would like
to to examine and specifically within
the American context we looked at
whether African American patients
receive longer durations of aggressive
treatment at end-of-life and they do so
this is just one line query correct they
do receive longer durations of these
treatments and the hypothesis we wanted
to test is that could this be a result
of mistrust and the reason this was our
hypothesis is the doctors that we spoke
with suggested that when they have had
end-of-life care discussions in the
hospital often there is this lack of
trust with specifically with minority
patients they say doctors have never
been sort of trustworthy with me and so
now you're telling me that I'm dying and
I there's nothing can save me I don't
agree with that give me all the
treatments and
what we did is very simple from sort of
the the methodological point of view we
trained a model to detect mistrust in
notes by labeling known mistrust issues
in the notes so non-compliance is a
known issue within minority communities
the doctor says I would like to do a and
you say no I will not do a you am a
yourself against medical advice yourself
and then autopsy rates have been noted
in the epidemiological community as
being a marker of mistrust so a patient
dies and then you say well I really want
to check that they died from the cause
that you say they died from I'm going to
go relatively quickly through the rest
of this so that I have time for the
ending matter so we train a model using
features that we extract it so we learn
based on a subset of labeled examples of
mistrust and this is based on
non-compliance and autopsy and it's
looking at things that you might imagine
that it would look at and then we train
on a larger set of data to try to say in
patients where we can't look at every
single note but if we label a subset of
them and say we know what mistrust and
Trust looks like in these notes in this
data we can generalize that to a larger
population and once we have these
mistrust scores we found that they are
primarily depending on things like
agitation and whether the patient is in
pain as extracted from the notes and
when you look at the interaction with
race the medium black patient has a
statistically significantly higher
mistrust score than white patients but
this is not just race so we look at
whether we can explain the treatment
disparities by race you can explain away
more of the treatment disparity more of
the gap between populations using a
mistrust score than just using race so
there's an interaction there that's not
completely captured by race and second a
rebuttal that you might have is well
maybe they're just sicker and so they're
not just sicker right because these
acuity scores that are standard in the
hospital like Oasis and saps are
correlated with one another but they are
not correlated with a mistrust score the
mistrust core is actually correlated
with things like autopsy that we know
are related to trust so that's it for
sort of research there are three things
that I wanted
to cover for future work or things I
think are important before leaving which
are number one epochs is not new in
health right so in healthcare we've had
to deal with drug pricing opioid
epidemic retracted studies conflicts of
interest clinical trial populations
being non representative the sort of new
thing from my perspective in this
community is ethical machine learning
how we do algorithm development
correctly and it's because when you do
ml and health there are questions beyond
the obvious like these human
interactions and whether you are making
things better or worse by using a model
right it's learning on biased data but
we we already are regulating these
things right so this is it's happening
it's not like we can just pretend that
it's it's not a thing it's actually
happening and so I think it's important
to recognize that there is opportunity
because in Eric Topol paper and a new
book he actually highlights that there
is at or above human level performance
in specific tasks and so the opportunity
is there so the second thing I want to
emphasize is under ad understanding
trust in the way that we try to address
using these clinical notes in the second
study has a real impact and so we know
there have been really really
fascinating studies done on randomizing
whether a patient gets preventive
treatment advice from from somebody of
the same race and it works significantly
better in things like likelihood of in
hospital mortality and in getting
patients to actually do preventative
invasive tests and a majority of this
reduction is in minority populations so
for example black patients with black
doctors and gender concordance actually
this is one of my favorite quotes from a
paper ever so in the third study gender
concordance increases a patient's
probability of heart attacks survival
but but mortality rates decrease when
male physicians practice with more
female colleagues or have treated more
female patients in the past this is
worrying for me have you seen a computer
science auditorium like the gender
balance is not great so what this means
is that this is fixable right if
performance gets better as you work with
more women for example in this case and
maybe it would get better in a
minority groups riot or women are not a
minority group but unless you're in
computer science then maybe we can fix
this maybe this is something we can
address maybe people can be trained to
interact with different groups groups
that are not the same as them so that
they engender trust and that would be
really really transformative because
once okay once I was giving a talk in a
room of tech CEOs and one of them raised
their hand and was and asked me you know
so you're trying to make you know
algorithms you know like cutting edge so
that all doctors can be like dr. house
and I thought are we watching the same
show hey do we want doctors to be like
dr. house he's a drug addict he's mean
to people so we probably have this
wonderful space where we can actually
help doctors do better doctoring because
there's also a really fantastic research
that demonstrates that the compassionate
interaction and not even a lot of it
just a little of it improves patient
outcomes across a really wide range of
conditions and the final thing I'll say
is that we should be treating house data
as a resource there is a play right now
amongst companies to lock up data
resources in the health space and then
you operationalize that into products
but we should be creating cutting-edge
research with these resources and we
should keep them in the public sphere
because we as a community have a
decision to make so in the machine
learning community you know you're
you're on a hiring committee every
machine learning Department every
computer science department hires sort
of a theory person in machine learning
and they'll hire a crypto person they'll
hire a vision person nobody hires speech
people anymore they haven't for like a
decade do you know why it's because ten
years ago faith Bailey made the decision
at Stanford to open the image net
dataset so vision can be done at
state-of-the-art level academically in
the open public space but about eight
years ago Amazon started their Alexa
project and that data is owned by Amazon
the Google home data that's on
Google you cannot do cutting-edge speech
research in academia it's not possible
when I have a student come and talk to
me I say well unless we have a company
giving us that data there isn't public
resource available for you to get the
same performance and so as a machine
learning for health community and I
would say as a broader health interested
community we should make a very strong
conscious choice as was made for these
communities about whether we want our
data to stay in these spaces thank you
[Applause]
I'll just come in in general we're going
well like I don't have solutions so I'm
really happy to be here and I really so
I'm gonna be presenting the problem we
ran within solutions but I hope we can
okay so where am I so I've put
everything on the slide so hopefully we
can I have too many slides so I will try
to go quickly so I don't know if I need
to say this to this crowd but in
contrast to 19th century European
anthropologists and biologists who
classified humans into what they
considered to be biologically different
racial categories everybody else it
seems historian sociologists as well
just some biologists hopefully computer
scientists I have been writing about
racism as not being equivalent to
genetic or biological biologically
distinct populations especially since
World War II to social science and
historical researchers have emphasized
that race and ethnic categories are
social political and historical
constructions that differ by locale and
era but in the 21st century conceptions
of racial groups is almost equivalent
different equivalent different genetic
groups has been on the rise again
especially with respect to certain
members of media we all love to hate
certainly I won't go into that I took
that slide out but I also by social
scientists and sociologists and some in
my department have been talking about so
so this is where my concern comes from
and might the concern of my group so the
larger context then is the resurgence of
this resurgence of racial genetics was
the transformation of biology into big
biology big data so that's what I'll be
talking about today
a medical geneticist
it's built data infrastructures to allow
them to conduct large-scale analyses to
search for genomic risks for for disease
common complex disease among the 3
billion DNA base pairs so we studied the
processes by which geneticists built big
data infrastructures and how the
information produced by those data
infrastructures was used in medical
genomics research
we're with nog referred so we go and
live in the lab and interview people and
study their algorithms and study their
databases
okay so genomic risk markers for common
complex disease and compared to clearly
population linked diseases caused by
single genes so we all know what those
are but I can talk about it common
complex disease research focuses of mm
focused on efforts to locate genomic
risk markers for warsi CDs researchers
were hoping that they could find genomic
markers or snips and I'll talk about
that more that would lead them to genes
for disease now the the scene has
changed entirely because there it's been
very difficult to identify genes for
disease so now the snips have become
risk markers themselves so they've been
transformed into risk markers but people
forget about that early history the
constructed genome-wide associations
that they constructed there should be Y
which are large-scale studies that use
statistical methods to search for
associations between single nucleotide
polymorphisms or snip differences
between people with the disease and
without the disease so there's cases and
controls okay am i saying what people
already know I just know okay good
information okay well I have three
slides but I will stop when I stop I
have cut I have cut from 45 but I will
stop I have major conclusions at the end
but I will stop I think it's important
to get this information out so I will
stop when I have to stop so just let me
know when I decide so snips so at the
beginning they estimated that they were
point 1 percent of the journal more
point 5 now it the number moves around
but so you know that we have three
billion nucleotides and so so this means
that they're about five million
nucleotides differences
that's very few really when you think
about it okay I have a slide that shows
event so beginning with the human genome
project genetics moved okay sorry I
changed I moved to Big Data genetics and
in this case statistical genomic
epidemiology they built infrastructures
as shortcuts to find markers that would
lead them to the many genes they
suspected were involved in common
complex diseases but each infrastructure
was not enough another we have a history
of the infrastructures in the book at
this time we have layers of
infrastructures each supporting the
other and each based on the other but in
complicated ways so now we're in the
time of big science and big data
so these are just some of the
infrastructures so we start they started
with the human genome project but of
course you know there were several
projects before that the haplotype
mapping project but there were several
projects before that Janome wide
Association studies is what we've been
talking about technologies like I
construct which is against rut is
basically a PCA principle component
analysis standard and statistics but I
construct was a particular version of it
since then there are multiple versions
so it's just become it's sweeping the
world
that's the scary part because that's the
part that makes populations and so we're
looking at genomic differences and
genomic clusters these clusters were
produced by the onion strat program
actually by the sub programs within the
eigen Straub program and they've been
read by people in the media genetics and
even sociologists as showing that racial
categories map onto genetically so I
just wanted to give a sense that there
were different attempts before the
hapmap project became the final choice
of the National Institutes of Technology
so the DNA polymorphism discovery
resource was one the snip consortium in
2001 and then we ended up with a
haplotype so the winner of course is a
population-based sampling strategy that
includes the identification of a
population and I'll see more about that
using advice of human population
geneticists the medical geneticists
couldn't collect a DNA from specific
groups of people in different countries
they identified the groups in that first
version of the hapmap as the Yerba and
Ibadan Nigeria the Japanese in Tokyo Han
Chinese in Beijing who became part of
the project when they found out that the
Japanese were part of the project but of
course the geneticists thought oh well
the Chinese and the Japanese are the
same so we only need one so different
views Utah residents with northern and
western european ancestry most of them
were from the mormon communities so it's
a very interesting data set they were
not labeled as caucasian african
Japanese Chinese or Asian even but if
you sit in the lab of course everybody
uses these terms but then when they look
at me sitting in the lab at the at the
table they switch to these formal names
but they are always supposed to use
these formal names but if you know ok
the hapmap
the project design included practices
that shaped the subsequent use of the
hapmap data so in other words the ways
in which the groups are labeled even in
half map 3 shaped their subsequent use
and gos studies so their social
identified errs by race ethnicity nation
city so or for example in half map 3
they said the Gujarati in Texas so that
we're still identified as the Gujarati
but they were in Texas so this is the
this is the conceptual place in which
notions of groups and and other group
identifiers entered the search for
genomic disease risk markers let's see
so now so how did race become genomic
again this is not what I believe so so I
just wanted to put the the three major
the two major points that I try to talk
about in detail but I won't have enough
time but the International haplotype
mapping project produced these data sets
ok DNA data sets that were used the
eigen Strutt or PCA technology was used
to analyze it and produced plots that
basically represented populations so and
as I said more similar technologies have
been developed ok my
okay so that I can start compares DNA
across samples and generates genetic
variation scores they use these scores
to look for genetic associations for
disease I have we can talk about that in
more detail but you don't need that
right now
but hapmap selects particular snips by
population the snips were chosen from
groups identified by racial ethnic
national city names these snips were
then then became reference snips to be
used in statistical epidemiological
studies genetic epidemiological studies
so to authenticate the snips of the
individuals and groups used in study
population so we're talking about the
the hapmap samples used as reference
populations to authenticate the snips
that were used in study populations okay
okay so so I'm gonna just give you some
big conclusions that we can talk as
geneticists began to build big data
structures their socio-cultural
assumptions about race entered into
their scientific research practices and
became entrenched in their data
infrastructures these data
infrastructures form the basis of
subsequent research some of which made
it appear as if races were genetic
categories infrastructures were built
step by step to search for genes for CCD
but because of these cultural
assumptions called social cultural
assumptions about race were built into
several infrastructures using these
infrastructures human geneticists
constructed group population genetic
differences which looked like races were
equivalent so I just want to be clear
that you know I'm not saying that all
population geneticists should although
some people have said that but but I
want to make clear that they are doing a
particular kind of work and their work
produces populations which are technical
categories for them for whatever they
want to do with it their purposes they
understand that they're working with
these these tools under particular
conditions they have limited time money
technologies and the technologies change
through time so that's we're still
studying it
they take shortcuts they make
accommodations for their limitations
they also work with certain political
demands so so all of these produce first
approximations and genomic clusters are
one outcome of their exploratory
technologies so they refer to their
genetic clusters as populations and
populations are not races I want to make
that clear population geneticists
construct populations a set of genetic
categories using particular tools for
particular purposes
in this case searching for snips they're
not meant to represent real people in
real groups in the world and I have to
say this over and over actually
racialized groups are historical
productions made up of people with
histories in societies in particular
societies races on populations races or
social designations that differ by
context including nation different areas
within a nation different historical
periods institutional purposes histories
individual identity self designations I
mean just think about the way cell P how
people self-identify in this country
alone across the u.s. it's different I
mean I've been living in Hawaii for the
past year and it's you know we can talk
about the different identifiers that are
going on now okay racialized groups
omean went on 1986 I stand by that
genetic this is the glutens 1972
statement based admittedly on a
different set of data but it still
stands genetic differences within a
racial group are greater than the
genetic differences between racial
groups but infrastructure
infrastructures are not innocent they
carry with them practices some of which
become embedded in the infrastructure
the half map is only one such
infrastructure that incorporated notions
of population differences that could be
read as ancestral differences that could
be read by some downstream users as
racial differences cultural assumptions
were built in throughout and that's one
of the things that we are showing in the
larger book you know where we're
cultural assumptions get built in and
every step of the research we say that
we're basically doing an archeology of
infrastructures infrastructures are
built from the bottom up at say any
populations constructed through these
choices and infrastructures or
scientific work objects are not groups
of real people in the world so the
takeaway is that the populations
constructed by population geneticists
don't say anything meaning
about the biology of the groups the
ability to construct a cluster or a
population is not meaningful in the
context of traits especially for the
health purposes here data is all already
structured oh what I'm saying always
already structured you know in high
school your teacher tells you never to
use the word of always I will say that
here raw data is an oxymoron but then I
wanted to the last slide that I just
wrote it's yes so I already gave it to
us may seem soon disappeared there's
been a lot of critique of gos studies
but population clusters from various
algorithmic programs are proliferating
and spreading across the world and every
group thinks that they have produced the
best algorithm for constructing
population differences based on this
data based on the data collected through
the half map and the comparisons the
particular snips selected by the hapmap
and the comparisons with the study
populations so we can talk more about
this
Floris or is a bioethicists who has been
part of this project off and on pilar
romney rajagopal in' is a geneticist who
joined our group
and she'll dachshund is our statistician
he taught here ok thank you
[Applause]
third speaker is Nancy Krieger from
Harvard
oh wait
so I'm very glad to be here today and I
really appreciate the invitation I'm
hoping very much to learn from people
who are in very different disciplines
than mine I'm a social epidemiologist
I'm someone who's steeped in the history
of public health epidemiologic theories
of disease distribution and the politics
of public health data usually I tend to
give very formal talks but in the spirit
of this being a workshop I have some key
points and essentially one a riff off of
them and I'm going to start with a way
at first being transparent which is that
my vantage point is that of the Eco
social theory of disease distribution
which I first articulated in 1994 and
have been elaborating since we live
embodied this means that when we look at
our health and we look at our being we
look at ourselves at our bodies at any
point in time we are always embodying
the world in which we live both the
social world and the biophysical world
the larger ecologic context and there is
no way of understanding our health
without bringing both of those into play
and seeing how it comes into our bodies
which is then what we re experienced and
can call our health status and/or
disease status and that this is
essential to understand population
patterns of health disease and
well-being and especially how they
change over time
and also the magnitude of health
inequities defined in multiple
dimensions whether in relation to race
ethnicity economics other aspects of
class immigration refugee status
Nativity as well as gender sexuality etc
the other thing is that when we always
think about embodiment we have to think
about pathways embodiment and this
includes
understanding how injustice structures
the worlds in which we live and also how
equity can structure the worlds in which
we live and what that means for human
health this means looking at the
cumulative interplay of exposure
susceptibility resistance at multiple
levels across the life course and
historical generation so when you think
about studying any population it's at a
real time in a real place in a real
society it's not just something called
the population that's floating around in
the cloud or elsewhere and that puts
them always multiple levels from macro
to micro and they're all within us and
the history and so it's really key that
we understand there are huge
distinctions between what I would call
biological expressions of injustice that
is how we get health inequities that
reflect through the body and through our
and that includes a nine
that mind is in the body so it's both
somatic and mental health or and that
can be due again to the many forms of
injustice that we have versus what are
unjust interpretations of biology which
are premise on notions of long histories
of scientific racism scientific sexism
the list goes on and on and on where
interpretations of biology are
completely biased by the injustice that
affects how people think and that is
nothing new and it's also really
important building on points that you
are making to always understand what the
metaphors and mechanisms are that are
being invoked to explain patterns of
disease distribution at any point in
time and how they are contested and
another point is that there is always a
contest between ideas they're almost
always dominant versus alternative
framings we live in a public point in
time where the dominant is biomedical
individualism bringing in a social
justice and social determinants of
health standpoint or if you were in
Latin America it might be called
collective health or it might be called
social medicine it would give you a very
different vantage point so to assume
that there is just one way of knowing
and interpreting what the epidemiologic
data are and the theories that are used
is not true there's actually lively
contacts other points building partly
off of what Joan was saying is a day to
never speak for themselves the word data
comes from Latin it's the past
participle of dari which means that
which is dari needs to give datum is
that which is given nothing's ever given
people always obtain data they analyze
data and they interpret data so and and
that's always again in the context of
their times and whether that is
challenging dominant frameworks for
example the United States challenging
dominant frameworks of white supremacy
versus actually in just going along with
them which is what a lot of the science
does so nothing is ever given we work
and we work hard to do our science and
what it also means is that we need to
have historically informed theories not
just data to evaluate the quality and
biases of data including us for the
first speaker in part who and what is
missing and that's again very much in
terms of the context of the long history
of scientific racism and its many guides
as which in this country was uniquely
formed in the context of the history of
settler colonialism and enslavement and
the expropriation of the wealth and
denial of Rights community cultures and
humanity of
and slave populations and this history
has informed each and every generations
debates over patterns of population
health and health inequities very much
so about the impact of racism on health
versus is or is it because people are
just somehow uniquely different and
there are racial superiority and
inferiority give me a technology in
health there will have been a debate
about this around racial inequality and
health it just keeps coming up where at
the time we are in our history with the
new technologies both in the computing
sciences and the biological sciences to
have new sets of debates and I'll be
giving concrete examples so another
corollary is that we need to have
historically informed theories not just
data to understand the kinds of
structural injustice that exists and
that shape not only conscious and
unconscious bias but even the incentives
for building systems of data including
artificial intelligence and to what end
and that means also entice very much
dealers come to comments about
understanding what are the incentives
that come with individualism and
methodological individualism and
assuming that you can just get data off
of people and somehow get that from that
to quote-unquote populations versus
understanding that you need to start
actually with structural data and where
does that take you and understanding how
individuals are embedded within
structures societies and context so the
last sort of general theoretical point
before coming to some concrete examples
is that you also need an awareness of
history as a precondition to predicting
the future because otherwise what will
happen is if you join a eve prediction
off of what we have now it means
injustice will continue in perpetuity
how do you understand change and how do
you understand the human capacity to
imagine and to create not just simply
destroy and consume to predict a future
based on past injustice will is a
political not an empirical choice so I
can even just name the changes that have
happened in my lifetime given my age I
mean I was born in the US and at that in
1958 so that means that I was alive when
it was the 1964 Civil Rights Act the
1965 Voting Rights Act the 1968 Fair
Housing Act all part of the abolition of
legal Jim Crow as well as the creation
of the Environmental Protection Agency
the Occupational Safety and Health
Administration new levels of regulations
of environmental occupation exposures
legalization of a
version Roe versus Wade of course
legalization also more recently of
same-sex marriage and these are all
things now subject to severe backlash
this all affects health how can we
understand the health scene in records
without contextualizing the historical
context and what that means for the
changes of the Dimmu nation and then the
expansion of health inequities so let me
now give some empirical examples on Bank
and where there are key problems and
pitfalls looking at uncritical
applications of AI to population health
data has the potential to cause harm and
and already has caused harm and to
organize my examples of rely on a schema
that I've recently developed for paper
that's under review right now to talk
about structural measures individual
level measures an individual of exposure
and it also internalized measures of
exposure to racism and with the
structural it's really important to be
clear that there is first what are the
unjust rules of the game those are rules
about that explicitly discriminate on
the basis of race ethnicity has happened
for example with Jim Crow and also with
historical redlining which is about the
government supported legal residential
segregation in the 1930s that has had
its impact on neighborhood trajectories
and remember neighborhoods of
trajectories not just people there are
the implicit unjust rules so for example
when you do things slate of hand you
have a poll tax this doesn't mention
race per se but it's clearly meant with
racial animus and racial bias this
really matters in terms of jurisprudence
in terms of whether you're supposed to
prove intent versus whether you look at
inequities and outcomes and then there's
a lot that's in the literature right now
that's being called structural that's
really area based measures of group
differences and lumping them in indices
so if you look at differences in
employment and education levels and
income what not you come with an index
and you call it structural and I'm not
quite sure that really is structural but
it is an area base that's reflects the
footprint of what have been other kinds
of practices and instance and systemic
practices that lead to what those group
differences are the individual level of
the exposure is about people are self
reporting their experiences of racial
discrimination and those are always
things that you have to always have
caveats about because there's a lot of
things that affect what people will say
in terms of whether they are able to
articulate what their experiences are
whether they trust you the form whatever
to report those
variances and there's a ways to deal
with what those kinds of biases are but
a lot of studies don't do that and you
can never take these data at face value
and then similarly you'll have measures
as I said of the internalized racism
which are all three levels which can
affect how people interact with others
will interact treat themselves and their
own bodies what does that mean in terms
of what their health status will be so
to give some examples empirically first
if one relies only on individual level
medical records and medical data is
collected in most hospital settings
separate from the question of how badly
the racial ethnic data are collected
because there's still a lot of data that
just comes from the medical record that
was decided by the medical staff and
never actually asked the patient and
very bad systemization of what those
data are across records it means you
will have absolutely Zippo data on
whether people self-report any
experiences of racism what their
internal racialism is but above all
you'll have absolutely no structural
measures and you rarely will have
measures that even contextualize what
kind of were they seen in a community
health center versus what the funding is
you have states in the u.s. which have
terrible Medicaid policies and you have
states which have better Medicaid
policies Massachusetts where I'm from is
somewhat better but if you don't know
what's going on in the system level all
you're gonna see is what's reflected in
an individual patients record which gets
back to the individual level
individualism and methodologically that
says that you can just study lots of
individuals and that equals
understanding of populations it doesn't
there's the long reach of history for
example not only that you don't know the
current context but I'm doing work for
example that shows the continued impact
of Jim Crow and the health of people who
are living now until teen that
specifically in relation to Jim Crow and
breast cancer estrogen receptor status
which is really important in terms of
therapeutics and what it means for the
likelihood and showing that there's a
strong Jim Crow effect for
african-american women and not white
woman that if they are born in a Jim
Crow State it matters for the kinds of
breast cancer estrogen receptor status
that they have going forward now and
that's not ancient history because when
you think about embodied history you
know it's like a lot of people that are
sick and getting chronic medical care
now and dying or in their 60 70 80s
hello and was Jim Crow legal when were
they born when were their parents born
what does that mean that kind of
understanding of history gets completely
lost in frames that look just at
the patient data now and just at the
individual level similarly you can look
and said well we're doing I'm going to
go through a bunch of examples and
mindful of time so the other thing is
that it's also really important to be
aware that people are using and some of
the epidemiologic studies quote unquote
big data coming from the internet I saw
there's something of a title of this
conference about not internet data but
we're being used as structural measures
of racism but the thing is again you
have to ask in more context because if
you also look like the latest and
n-double-a-cp report on the use of the
deliberate escalation of anti-black
rhetoric online for the 2016 elections
and what that means that there's a lot
that is fomented as well as comes from
what is ever else going on in the u.s
how do you treat you can't treat those
data at face value either if you don't
understand something about context and
so I think these are all and then the
last thing to say about the contextual
structural level isn't opals new book on
big data and medicine there's this
astounding chart to the end at the end
which has this thing that looks at the
different levels that you could look at
it data so there's like from the person
on down there are a zillion levels about
every single omics that you can imagine
and then there's one line at the top
about social context that's a problem in
a really big way and it just and and so
I think that it's really key to
understand that actually I could extend
and people that are even in the social
sciences could take that one and go like
a way up and be understand that you're
dropping you're looking at an individual
at a moment in time what is that time
historically as well as where they are
actually in their individual life course
in terms of infant young toddler kid
adult etc secondly this has been alluded
to by other speakers there's huge issues
that you're going to be dealing with
quote-unquote medical or public health
data about classification
misclassification and exclusion is tied
to the histories over scientific racism
and the politics of public health data
for example consider the data on the
what on what the group that gets lumped
by US census terms is American Indian
in aid of the United States there has
been a lot of work to try to fix the
incorrect Mis classification in
mortality records and actually over time
the amount of miss classification of
race ethnicity in terms of you ask
people and you compared to what they
said before what they say no obviously
they don't say anything when they're
dead but before they died or else what
family members say you'll see the
dispersed virtually non-existent in this
classification now for people that are
labeled quote-unquote white and black
almost non-existent about two percent
for Hispanic it's forty percent for
American Indian native and that means
and it also of course varies by region
of country depending on which nations
and tribes are involved and what that
also means is that there are actually
are some very good work that's underway
right now that's being led by some of
the American Indian epidemiologic units
that are attached to both IHS and also
freestanding because urban Indians are
of course not covered by Internet the
IHS is to actually try to start
combining data across health records and
also with data linkage and concerns
about privacy social security employment
records whatnot to try to come up with
better data because if you've got
terrible numerator data and terrible
denominator data guess what you get
terrible rates it's just a given so
that's a place where you could see that
there could be really helpful use of AI
to help work on that but if you don't
understand what the problem is socially
politically and historically and also to
understand the different histories of
the message' nation laws that have
happened in this country around American
Indians and not just african-americans
you don't understand what that story is
similarly it's also really cleared but
you measuring and this has been alluded
to measuring something like race even
self-reported is not the same as asking
whether you've smoked cigarettes or not
it's a very different kind of category
it's not the stable little variable
looking at the data on the exit of who
changes what through what's called by
some of the demographers racial churning
who reports what race in 2010 versus
2000 census you get a lot churning what
a kid says when the parents in the room
versus when the parents not in the room
you get changes that's part of
understanding the social lived reality
of what this race ethnicity so it looks
like a nice neat little variable in your
data set it never is that and it also
matters by the way and the Nativity and
immigration is that there's increasing
work that's now showing that you can't
just talk about immigration healthy
immigrant effects because it also
depends with people of refugees and as
we're watching what's happening now with
the immigrants coming across the border
that was referred to by the first
speaker if you've got some of the
conditions of health and the people that
are dying now in detention centers I
wouldn't call that a healthy immigrant
effect similarly how people are deciding
to also cluster data and talk about data
talk about groups of outcomes if you
don't understand the history of
scientific racism you don't get it so
there's this whole discourse now about
deaths of despair
that's about basically looking at
mortality due to opioids predominantly
among white populations of particularly
middle age there's also really
interesting work that if you want to
call it deaths of despair to look at
homicide rates not just suicide rates
but also homicide rates that are
happening in for example specifically
the contrasts often made in
african-american communities aren't
those deaths of despair so not
understanding what the lenses means
framings of problems that can be really
problematic and they're not just
intuitive from the data the last point
for many of you who might be playing
with population-based data population
survey data all the huge big US surveys
are done on the non institutionalized
civilian population well that's a lot of
people fine except a who's missing
everyone who's incarcerated be everyone
in the military and see everyone who is
otherwise institutionalized that really
matters if you're concerned about
inequities and you miss them and there's
been really interesting work that's been
done more in sociology looking at for
example if you try to look at the
black/white difference as an income or
employment if you lop off the
incarcerated population you end up with
really distorted understandings of what
the progresses are not there's been a
little work like that in health but not
enough so it's again if you're really
trying to think about how do you
understand who's missing and who isn't
systematically and why in the data
that's going to be analyzed this is more
than just about external validity this
is also about entire ranges of exposures
that are not absolutely being considered
so the last points that I want to bring
up are ones that are about the unjust
rules of the game that can happen
algorithms and they were already alluded
to by the first speaker about diagnostic
biases there's been really clear work
that shows differential approaches to
appraising pain and also differential
accuracy and diagnosis but there's also
the question of whether certain
therapies or interventions are bringing
in a quote race lens or not and so
there's a paper that's just come out
about challenging what is done uniquely
in the US of a quote unquote race
correction for vaginal birth after
cesarean section when no such race data
are included for example in Canadian
data and in European data and instead
looking at mainly the economic
indicators as well as age and also that
funny thing called comorbidity because
people aren't we remember we're all in
one body so you don't just sort of have
an illness you usually have an illness
in the context of a lot of other things
going on
people don't just prove that prior
example people routinely have diabetes
hypertension and sometimes cancer at the
same time and it seems to be you know I
will do a lot of work in the cancer
world and it's like this you're always a
huge discovery to people that there's
multi morbidity it's like really not and
whatnot and how does that mean if you
again if you don't take those parts
together you've got a real problem in
understanding what the who and who is
being studied how with what inclusion
criteria and that really matters and I
say this on a premise of saying that as
humans by and large we have pretty
similar biology and it's not a good deal
to have diabetes cancer in hypertension
at the same time and what that's gonna
mean for treatment and what it's gonna
mean for treatment not only in the
medical terms but also what it means for
somebody in the context of their family
and support if they even have a family
it's it's really important to take that
into account so the last point is that
it's really important also in the little
bit that I've been looking at some of
the kinds of claims that are going to be
made on turning on better predicting
things there's a lot of framing of delay
in seeking care in the cancer literature
particularly you can see this in
cervical cancer what this completely
misses is that it puts it back up just
like with quote-unquote non-compliance
it puts it completely on the patient
it's not like what's the transportation
system how are they followed is there a
patient navigator or not who makes sure
that things happen because a lot of
women get the screens for cervical
cancer but then they never get treated
they fall in between the huge crack what
and then it's called delay in seeking
care but it puts it on the person if we
have systemic analyses that take into
account the structural factors of what
the incentives are about who gets
treated how who's brought in who's moved
along we end up with these inequities
that always end up getting put back to
the bias of individual methodological
approaches and just strong individuals
but gets put back on the person like
they delayed seeking their care not work
we're all the obstacles to their care
and you will not find those obstacles in
people's medical records by themselves
you always have to link to other
datasets I've helped people at one of
the hospitals in Boston show where the
diabetes patients that are having the
most trouble they're in the
transportation quote-unquote deserts in
Boston and if you think that you can
park your car near any of the major
Boston hospitals good luck
especially if you don't want to like
lose you know over a day's worth of
wages for the parking lot and the last
point there too is that in terms of the
appraisals of qualities of care again
very few indicators in any way will show
up quality of care in relation to
people's experiences of racism and I
think that and and I'd actually differ a
little bit on the framing of trust a lot
of the trust literature in the medical
literature gris search does not really
engage well with why there is the
mistrust to seeing that the patient has
a problem to fix as opposed to there's a
problem and the systemic racism in the
health institutions so my only points
then are is that to work with big data
and to work with computer algorithms and
to work with health data is to really
understand that we need to grapple with
history understand the moment in what
you're doing the research understand
what the theories are that you need to
bring that give the array of exposures
that are at multiple levels happening
over time in life course as well as
historical generation to understand the
errors of omission and Commission and
the population health data that will be
fed into the algorithms and that these
out that these errors will be compounded
and not reduced if one relies only on
the existing individual level health
data and did not take into account both
the biases of this level and the failure
to include the relevant contextual data
on exposure to racism at multiple levels
in historical context
[Applause]
okay
all right thank you for having me I'm
gonna talk about two papers today it's
with quite a array of people that I've
listed here but they're primarily the
work of Emma Pearson one of them and
then Ziad obermeyer for the other at
this stage in my career I'm not really
sure what my role is so basically what
I'd like to do is talk about two
empirical projects that try to touch
that a really just sort of in healthcare
and I thought both of them touched on
the role of algorithms in it and
inequity in the delivery of care I don't
I think the each tells a very different
story
quite distinct I think but yet I think
each story is itself typical of a kind
of thing that we've encountered in our
world a background I used to do a lot of
work empirical work in behavioral
science having focused on discrimination
in the last five years I've been working
a lot on machine learning applications
and so for me this area is one where I
come at it with the sort of the dual
lens of thinking about human bias and
also just thinking about it
algorithm bias and so both of these
narratives both of these papers speak to
that so the first one involves something
Nancy touched on which is comorbidity
for those who don't know care
coordination programs are a pretty
common program in the United States and
increasingly around the world and the
basic point of pair coordination program
is to recognize that if you look at
health care costs a fraction of people
account for a lot of costs and in
particular it's people with these many
comorbidities they are people who've got
a lot going on and these people are in
many ways the epicentre of costs and
programs have been designed to target
these people with extra resources so it
kind of makes sense that if you're going
to show up a lot at the hospital or at
your er or whatever it might be that we
ought to treat you differently so these
programs are actually very good and if
you could you'd love to be enrolled in
them
for example typically you get a nurse
assigned to you and so whenever you feel
anything you're asked to call the nurse
and then the nurse will tell you whether
to come in or not and then when you went
in you have your own special Lane and
you don't go to the front desk they know
you're coming and you go straight there
straight and you're taken care of
immediately
one of the things that people hate in
this literature is to refer to these
programs as frequent flyer programs but
so I won't do that I'm learning from our
president on how to talk too hard to
target patients we have to decide who is
eligible for a care coordination program
these were expensive so we want to give
them and it turns out we often talk in
this literature on algorithms that could
be scaled this is one of the largest
kind of algorithm that has already used
at scale there's probably about over a
hundred million patients every year
running through these programs through
these algorithms to decide who is going
to get a care coordination program so
what I want to do today in this first
project is to ask let's take one of
these live algorithms we have one from
one company and it's kind of the largest
one of the largest companies in the
space probably a little more than it's
hard to get exact numbers let's say tens
of millions of people are run through
this program through this algorithm and
so it exists and what I want to look at
is well how inequitable is this program
is this algorithm and I want to
particularly look at equity through the
lens of who's getting into the program
so we're trying to get the sickest
people and so let's ask the question
what kinds of and we're just gonna use
whites and blacks for now what kinds of
whites and blacks are let into the
program and specifically I'm just gonna
look at a simple calibration curve given
a score that the algorithm is outputted
at every score level what is the
realized health of whites or blacks very
straightforward there are other things
we can use and we can get into that
discussion and there's a amazing
literature on these things but this is
just as an empirical exercise a good
place to start now we've got a bunch of
measures but in the interest of time I'm
going to show you something called the
Gagne score which is a pretty good
summary statistic of your m9 mature
saying that right but it sounds more
fancy it's GA GNE I'm sure there are
plenty of ways to pronounce that but I'm
sure Ghani I can't say my last name
either so what I want to do is I want to
put the score up for that and if people
are interested we've done this for many
measures that might be more familiar to
you such as hba1c which is a measure for
diabetes or blood pressure or things
like that but here's what we have we
have the risk score on the x-axis and
then by race we've got the realized
health and what you can see is that at
every level of the score blacks are
sicker quite a bit sicker so for example
the auto enrolment threshold for this
program is right here this is the 97
point you're at this score you are to
enrolled in this program the gap if we
zoom in have 28% more chronic illness
illnesses for blacks at this threshold
and the equivalent white at the same
score level and it's true of many other
health outcomes as I just said let's go
through a calculation of how big this
effect is through a very simple
simulation like super trivial the super
simulation is a zoom into this area I
just did this because I I am my
co-author made this and I just think
it's amazing to zoom in so what you have
is zoomed in to that region this is the
the curve for blacks occur for white
what would it mean to equal equal equal
eyes it would mean wow these very sick
blacks are not getting in and these far
less six whites are getting in let's
simulate adding and replacing until we
have an equal so I'm going to add those
people into the program remove those
people until we reach sort of a same
health score if we did that the fraction
of blacks in the program would double
from about seventeen point seven percent
to thirty six point one percent so the
gap is very sizable so what's happening
where's the algorithm going wrong and I
should I should say by the end of this I
hope you'll see this one manufacturer I
think is got this problem but I'm almost
certain they all have this problem once
you see what I think is so where's the
algorithm going wrong there's a lot we
can get into we could talk about the
underlying data we could talk about how
there are biases and the data they're
training on and truly they all could be
playing a role
but one telltale sign of where the
algorithm is going wrong is actually
where the algorithm is going right so I
put health on the y-axis now a different
thing I could have put on the y-axis a
similar calibration curve is not looking
at calibration by health but looking at
calibration by dollars spent and it
turned out perfectly calibrated no
racial gap whatsoever
it's kind of interesting and so what's
happening so the problem is that I gave
you this narrative about we're trying to
get the sicker people etc but health
care costs are not the same as health
outcomes in the policy literature people
are both careful about this distinction
and also kind of free and loose about
the distinction because empirically
costs are health I mean if you get a
claim database actually you're not
looking at health you're actually kind
of looking just the dollars what is
insurance claim and why does this matter
it's because if I put health on the
accident just in the interest of time I
won't go through this it's obvious to
all of you but you put health on the
x-axis simple costs on the y-axis guess
what those two are positively related
very strongly positive related but on
the other hand there's a gap at the same
level of health blacks end up costing
less so the previous speaker mentioned
access issues about people showing up
etc so there's a big difference and
simply whites have better access to
health care and at every level of health
that's costly so accurate cost
prediction unbiased accurate cost
prediction which is what we have here
does not mean that we have unbiased
health prediction we actually have
pretty biased health prediction
so it was a dissect the problem there's
a proximate cause the label the
algorithm is optimizing one objective
the objective it was given in this case
they were building costs but that's not
our full objective we have you know we
care about health as a society but I
think that misses the point a little bit
which is we now should dig a little
deeper and for this I cannot give you
firm answers but I can give you some
speculation before moving on why was
cost chosen and not health after all
somebody chose that label not just one
person there was a whole system choosing
this label the algorithm manufacturer
the purchaser of these algorithms so
what are two things well as a economists
or maybe item a tonight you know for me
you don't have my passport anymore I'm
not sure but maybe all the the guards
are at the real border and I'm still
allowed in I'm not sure but as a former
economist you might say ah this is
obvious its incentives follow the money
hospitals and insurers care about
dollars society cares about health
why do you expect insurers and hospitals
to focus on health or less extremely
health systems care more about costs
then than we do and you could say look
you're not rediscovering and you're
rediscovering an old obvious thing we've
known about health care independent of
algorithms independent just in the
structure of these systems many problems
in health care and healthcare delivery
arise from the incentive problem that
the deliverer is worried about costs and
we as society care about health net of
cost externalities abound in health care
this is simply an example of an
externality so I think the follow the
money incentive externality view at
least has some our priors should be
there let me propose a second view it's
misunderstanding and I could put this
view in in a few ways it's first worth
noting even in policy conversations we
conveniently use costs to talk about
health it's easy to find papers
published in good journals important
papers where they talk in the abstract
about health you dig deep and they're
like oh they're actually using costs
it's just interchangeable in a way and
the cost label was chosen through a
combination of convenience
and simply not understanding the
consequences because in most papers you
work on using cost versus health because
they're so highly correlated the the
error is like well okay I could get much
better health data but the cost date is
much easier to get and the error is some
approximable error now one reason I'm
more prone to the misunderstanding view
um the first speaker I thought highlight
that beautifully woah it's early days
and things we just don't understand
stuff and so these algorithms are going
to scale but it's not clear we
understand all of the dangers imposed in
them so it's totally possible there is
just misunderstanding and the
differences matters if you believe it's
the incentive view we need pretty large
policy correctives like we need
elsewhere in the health system and
that's reasonable and you believe in the
latter view the misunderstanding view
then I think we need a lot more more
work by like people in this audience and
forgets things out there because it is
the work we do that is going to have
dramatic effect I don't have an answer
but I will give you one little clue
after we did all this I don't know why
we did this I actually you can you might
ask why don't you do this earlier but
after the paper was finished we said
well why not simply contact them
algorithm after the manufacturer hey he
got this out isn't this a problem know
what your prior is I can tell you what
my prior was and oh I'm not gonna I
can't say if you'd like but I'm I think
I'm gonna not say at this point and
here's why I don't want to say it's just
a choice I think by implying them I
think as you see the problem I
subscribed all of the algorithms in this
space do this and I would rather not say
oh they did it's not the entire space is
complicit in this and it is you just
pick one they all did this so I know
about your prior but my prior I can buy
reveal preference my prior was revealed
by the fact that I said to Z yet why
don't you contact them and
so you know it turns out they were super
responsive they said my god can we work
with you to try and understand the
problem and fix it they then took our
thing replicated in their data on sort
of 3.7 billion patients and said yeah
Wow there seemed to be something then
they proceeded to ask well what kind of
fixes could be get and started trying to
build fixes I don't know what that means
you can be cynical and say they're
getting their front running a problem a
publicity problem before okay I have no
idea and just telling you the facts and
it made me think there's some complexity
to this issue that is different let's
see okay so I'll skip this in the
interest of time they this is the the
method they're developing the correct I
think we can do better I think that but
already they've sort of had an 84%
reduction of the problem but I think
it's the kind of thing where if as more
people work on it they at least would be
open to implementing okay so let me move
to the second project it's a first story
I hope it's kind of clear the second
project comes from something in the
world of social insurance I've worked on
poverty in the past and one of the more
striking facts about us social policy
that people don't understand is that I
think well I don't know if many of you
know about redistributed programs like
AITC EITC is one of the big
redistributed programs
well most people don't understand is
that disability insurance has become one
of the major transfer programs in the
United States you simply look at dollars
going to the poor over the last three
years disability insurance for the big
source of it more importantly the most
common source of disability is arthritis
and back knee spine problems so it's
actually if you said what is a big
correlate of poverty and getting
resources in the United States you'd
actually end up with osteoarthritis you
don't really think of it it's the most
common joint disorder in the United
States about ten percent of people over
60 and thirteen percent of people women
over 60 have knee arthritis here's how
we know how arthritis is bad you take an
x-ray and clinicians look at the x-ray
there's a name for these clinicians but
I can't say that words I was going to
say
clinician the and then they grade it
they say oh look at this knee unlikely
to have arthritis and then it's mild
moderate severe there's a good grading
system established clinical protocols
and the higher the grade the worse and
so any grade above - you're you're
classified as having osteoarthritis but
we have a different way to understand
what the patient is feeling which is we
can ask them so something called the
crews pain score which amongst its most
frustrating features is that a higher
couth pain score means less pain it
makes sense so I just think they want to
do that every time you use it feel a
little pain yourself which I thought
it's brilliant in its own way I will
admit so we can also ask patients how
are you know your pain level and if you
ask them your pain level you find a
striking fact that's been found
repeatedly and David Cutler whose
co-author on this paper has this fact in
another paper and I just found it
striking which is at every level of
severity judged by clinicians those of
lower SES I'll focus on black/white
today but you find it with college and
I'll college income levels those of
lower SES experience more pain same
clinical severity more pain has some
consequences
since the severity grade influences
whether you get a surgery or you're just
told to just live with it or here take
some painkillers it means that given a
level of pain blacks are more likely to
be given not given treatment for that
pain
surgically I said you know hey this is
just a lifestyle you didn't need to live
with this thing why is there a pain gap
part of why I got interest in the
furniture is that it is a pretty
evocative idea that there's this pain
gap because it matches some of our
intuitions and of course there are other
reasons I'll tell you one of the more
evocative ones that the same physical
pain is felt more sharply if your lower
SES the the mind magnifies the physical
pain even when there are other acts you
know less access to medication different
coping strategy less social support we
can give a lot of these things you know
put all of these into a hypothesis that
I will describe as outside their knees
which is how I think I and many people
think about this which is that there are
non knee related factors that the same
knee problem results in more pain and so
there's another hypothesis what if the
problem is not something outside the
knee of the patient what if the problem
is something that's not in the heads of
the clinician looking at those x-rays
what if it's simply the case that as
Margie I mentioned her talk where did
this clinical knowledge come from in the
first place from data I guess we know
that data doesn't completely represent
lower SES people so what if the problem
is the clinical knowledge we have under
represents the ailments of the poor so
how would we test this hypothesis test
this hypothesis what we did is we've got
this data set on it's actually a
beautiful data set because unlike most
data sets to come from operating health
systems where you might get one read by
one clinician this is data set expressly
put together to understand
osteoarthritis it has a set of x-rays
patients were followed up consistently
it's a very clean data set we've got all
their x-rays we also have their MRIs but
we're not using that in this and we get
the judgment of severity is not some
clinician it is sort of a consensus
judgment where many were several people
look at it so it's kind of a good clean
judgment of what the current state of
medical practice leads us to believe but
we took that same data and said okay
here's the x-ray here's a clinician
judgment
what if instead of the clinician
judgment I simply trained an algorithm
to predict pain from the x-ray he here
is the algorithm only sees the x-rays it
is not told the ses of the patient so
what do we find first and I'll go
through these fast and numbers here are
somewhat less important but if people
are interested I can I can stop and slow
down but it turns out the algorithm does
predict pain better than just the
clinician judgment alone but importantly
if instead of ranking people by the KL
grade clinician judgment we rank them by
the algorithms prediction of pain it's
significantly norris narrows the pain
gap in the case of race it's completely
gone so you remember this figure KL
grade blacks at the same level
algorithmic judgment no difference at
all so what you see here is a slightly
different story than the previous story
but we'll try and bring it back together
as an aside this is not due to the
algorithm simply reconstructing race or
SES it is finding something in the image
it is not finding a back door way it's
not due to discrimination problems in
the KL great the gay out grade is five
scores ours is continuous and it's not
simply learning image artifacts it's
discovering something more fundamental
about the news finally another fact
which I'll just tell you about is that
our pain predictor also ends up
predicting progression because we've got
years of data so when we get people who
the algorithm says wow I see something
in this knee that's problematic the
patient agrees with us and the clinician
says now it's lo que el grade there's no
problem it's in your head and also in
the algorithms head if you go forward
two years that person the clinician ends
up saying oh wow the KL grade does look
worse now so in some sense when the
patient and the algorithm disagree with
the doctor the doctor eventually comes
to see you there with
so finally is just an observation using
the pain predictor to allocate to to
allocate surgeries would lead to more
treatment for low SES because it's
obviously so why did this happen I think
one hypothesis that just you know so
clear is it clinical knowledge is also
empirically derived derived as much as
we think about algorithms using training
data the scientific community is using
training data to train their minds
humans are using training data to track
that and that training data well who's
left out in clinical trials
what have we tended to look at what will
we look at and so there is I think
that's part of what's going on here let
me just conclude by saying this which is
I think these two things are emblematic
of things that we're starting to find in
a bunch of the healthcare work I will
emphasize a sort of somewhat trite but
also sometimes overlooked point which is
as you saw in the first case failures
and algorithm design can magnify biases
you saw in the second case well-designed
algorithms can dampen our biases there's
just no good or bad here it's just we've
got something the second point I want to
end on is to say design is not about
algorithm construction once the problem
is posed yes there are issues once we
pose the problem about how best to
manage clearly if I simply took the
machine learning applied computer vision
applied to healthcare playbook you know
what we would have people would have
done with that osteoarthritis initiative
data it's what people are doing right
now what will I have trained on I would
have trained on the kale grade and then
I would have simply baked back in the
bias and what would that paper have been
looking like the abstracts of that paper
would have read much like in the first
thing oh we use an algorithm this court
to discover severity severity what a
funny word it's not that we use the
algorithms to automate human or current
human understanding of severity
we kind of felt out at that level of
tediousness it shows there something
important so as a result I want to just
end by saying I think the one source of
bias error social problems that may
arise is the problem construction and if
you think about it I think in the world
of expertise this is the interstitial
space where something is falling through
and here's why on the one hand you must
be live and understanding all the things
machine learning algorithms actually do
and can't do and fail at and are prone
to and so on so you must understand
enough of what happens once the problem
is posed at the same time you must
understand enough about arthritis and
about this domain to be able to say oh I
see where the problems are and so I
think one of the challenges we face and
a very real challenge in both of these
problems is who owns problem
construction who is expert at problem
construction if you put two groups in
the same side an algorithm team who
understands algorithms and a hospital
chain that understands healthcare a
weight that is what happened in the
first one so it can't be that there is
genuine expertise I think that sits at
this level and I don't think we we won't
we feel only started to scratch the
surface of that expertise and what that
would look like
[Applause]
searches mudslides but too late probably
so I have in mind here
it's fine yeah
Oh
it's okay I can just push that I'll just
push that
okay great hi everybody so what I want
to focus on is the question for our
panel about race and health inequities
and seeing all these people know that
I'm up here and in particular the
problem of prediction and I think it's
it's very gratifying to me that my talk
is going to touch on everything
everybody else said some piece of it is
in is incorporated here you may have
noticed if you were following all the
different notices of this workshop that
I switched among three different panels
what's that one point on carcere ality
and one point on public policy and
unfortunately because I can't be here
tomorrow I was switched on to this panel
but my questions are pretty much the
same for all of them because of my
particular interest in prediction and
its importance in in these issues we're
discussing and also the way in which
prediction is at the core of in justices
in analytics and big data and automated
decision-making so the questions I'm
asking are how can we end prediction as
a way of foreclosing social change so
the problem I see with a lot of
predictive analytics is that they're
based on data that incorporates passed
in justices and so what the algorithms
do is produce replications
of the past so my question is how can we
then design technological models like
was just asked in the last panel that
instead of incorporating these
assumptions and
facts of the past that embed structural
inequality we use the models design the
models to be able to envision a
different reality that is more equitable
humane and just and so can we use
forecasting technologies than to
envision a future that doesn't replicate
the past so if I were on the carcere
ality panel I would have emphasized the
way in which certain kinds of
law-enforcement technologies that
prosecutors and judges and police police
are using incorporate data that already
has racial profiling for example in it
and therefore end up reinforcing the
past biases and policing into future
policing practices or future predictions
of who's going to commit a crime and
race of course is very much involved in
all of that but since I'm on this panel
I want to focus on the way in which the
biological concept of race itself is a
tool predictive tool that incorporates
passed in justices and what do we do
about that what do we do about the way
in which race is so embedded in
healthcare technologies and even the
very practice of medicine so that we can
move to a way of using algorithms and
you know some of the panelists gave
examples of that that reject the
assumptions about race that unjust
medicine has been based on for centuries
and allow us to figure out better ways
of dealing with health that create more
equitable society for everybody and so I
want to just give some information about
how race is used in medicine as a
predictive tool
some years ago cellie say-tell wrote an
article that was the cover article for
the New York Times Magazine where she
said I'm a racially profiling doctor and
as many conservatives like to do they
make it sound as if they're saying
something bold and brave but actually
you know she's Alyssa's and color blind
so why is the tempo for doctors to take
note of a patient's race well of course
it isn't tempo medical students are all
taught that they should the first thing
they should do is take account of a
patient's race and then proceed to
interpret the patient's symptoms and
treat the patient prescribe medication
according to race based on the
assumption that human beings are
naturally divided into biological races
and therefore their bodies function
differently depending on race this is so
common that is embedded in medical
technology in a way that is outside the
individual doctors hands although I
don't understand why doctors don't rise
up and say this is absurd why are you
giving us these kinds of results based
on race but an example is go Merliah our
filtration rate which is routinely
reported by race so the the amount of
the protein in the patient's blood that
predicts for kidney function and tells
the doctor whether they should be
concerned about kidney failure and the
patient is automatically categorically
different for black patients versus non
black patients or I should say at non
african-american patients I'm not sure
what they mean by these categories in
the first place but the the in other
words the technology assumes that black
people's bodies work differently than
all other human beeings bodies we should
all be gasping all right this but this
is this is a current way that this this
test for kidney function is presented to
doctors well this is based on the
biological concept of race which a
couple of the panelists talked about
already which itself is a predictive
classification system so the the whole
purpose
of dividing human beings into biological
races is to put them in a hierarchy that
predicts their character and behavior
based on assumed innate traits it's is a
predictive biological classification
system of course as others have pointed
out it is an invented classification
system that pretends that there are
these biological differences but the
reason it functions so well to preserve
white supremacy is because of this false
assumption that it's embedded in nature
and not in social or inequality of power
in position so for example Thomas
Jefferson
I used the idea of natural biological
distinctions to justify enslavement and
after emancipation he said even then
black people couldn't participate in
democracy a way in which to explain why
there could be slavery in America at the
very same time that he and others were
promoting the view that America was a
land of equality and the pursuit of
happiness and liberty now this idea that
human beings are naturally divided into
races that predict their character and
behavior and therefore are is that that
natural classification is the cause of
racial inequality is also long embedded
in medical practice based on the racial
concept of disease that people of
different races have different diseases
and experience common diseases
differently this is an idea that still
is a bedrock of practice the practice of
medicine in the United States today but
again we can see that it was developed
in order to justify slavery
Samuel Cartwright for example proposed
that black people had less lower lung
capacity
than white people and had to be forced
to work in order to be healthy and the
spirometer which he helped to perfect is
another example of a predictive
technology in medicine that
automatically corrects in some versions
of it but there are lots of this disease
are just a few examples there are lots
and lots of technologies that
automatically correct for rate assumed
racial differences in bodily functions
now I could go on and on about all the
harms that this causes in medical
practice but I'll point to just one
which you mentioned which is the
well-documented
under treatment of black people for pain
and some of the studies have pointed out
that even when patients black patients
describe their pain as high severe or
when it obviously is severe like little
children being admitted in the emergency
room for appendicitis in severe pain
black patients are routinely given less
pain medication or no pain medication
compared to white patients in a recent
study out of University of Virginia
showed that the reason for this was that
medical residents and presumably doctors
as well hold these ideas about
biological difference among people of
different races and so they found that a
substantial number of white medical
students and residents believe things
like black people have thicker skin than
other human beings and so do not feel
pain as much black people have less
sensitive nerve endings and the
researchers found that these false
beliefs predicted a mistreatment of
black patients for pain
you know I haven't seen I I it's too
painful to think about but I can't
imagine that I I can I can tell you that
I when you say that it brings back a
memory of my taking my children to a
dentist in a in a white dentist in a
black neighborhood years ago where he
had a restraint in the yes there
restraining a jacket hanging in and I
left immediately but my thought then was
what is he doing to the children though
he's treating in this pipe okay so as
John Fujimura pointed out there has been
a resurgence of the biological concept
of race in genomic research and in
epidemiological research other kinds of
biomedical research since the mapping of
the human genome where these ideas about
biological race are being refurbished
with advanced algorithms and big data in
order to create and I this this idea
that race can be proven to be a natural
grouping of human beings and and also as
Nicholas Wade pointed out in the New
York Times a way to look for genetic
differences between human races and
usually the justification for this is to
improve health because this will assist
researchers in understanding health
inequities as being produced by innate
differences among different racial
groups and one study by Peter Chao white
and sandy Greene published in 2013 found
that there actually was a spike in
genomic research on race and genetics
using race as a biological category as
opposed to as a social construct
and again race being described by many
genomic researchers today as a
population that can be inferred from
genotype data based on statistical
probability so race itself as a
statistical grouping that then predicts
supposedly outcomes including health
outcomes so in other words race is a
itself a predictive risk factor that can
be used in algorithms and other ways of
predicting health one example of the use
of race itself independent of all social
factors as a predictive variable for a
negative health outcome is this
hypothesis that black race independent
of other factors increases the risk of
extreme preterm birth and it's frequency
of recurrence which got a headline in
the New York Times saying that this
study pointed to genetic differences
between races as being the cause of
higher rates of preterm births among
black women now as Nancy Krieger pointed
out this this view has been challenged
by research that is looking at the way
in which structural racism not race
produces these inequitable outcomes I
just want to point out that this is a
long-standing debate within health
inequity research that even Du Bois a
hundred years ago was arguing that the
dominant view which remains the dominant
view I think that it is innate
differences that produce health
inequities is wrong and that it is act
the conditions produced by structural
racism by political inequality that
causes these disparities in health so
racism not race as the risk factor that
should be used in a scientific research
to explain and end health inequities
just one example of a such research is
this study published in 2014 that looked
at the impact of living in states with
high levels of structural racism I think
Nancy Krieger gave some examples as well
from her work of similar kinds of
research looking at the effects of of
racism as opposed to the assumed natural
products of innate biological
differences so in conclusion I think
it's important to remember that race is
the product of racism racism is what
produced the invention of the false
assumption the false claim that human
beings are naturally divided into races
that predict not only health outcomes
but supposedly also predict their fate
in society you know as I say that you
can see that's also the basic thinking
of eugenics which in another talk we
could look at the relationship between
eugenics and statistical risk but the
same idea that it is some innate
difference among human beings that
produced social inequality that that
false belief is based on a view that
race is natural or well with respect to
racism racist a Turrell and that then
produces racism because of a supposed
human propensity to
hate people of other races or to be
biased against people of other races
when in fact racism came first and that
is the only reason to have a theory a
made-up theory of human beings is
naturally divided into races I think it
this to me helps to clarify what the
risk factor should be in algorithms that
are trying to improve health if you
understand the relationship between race
and racism and so in conclusion an
answer to the questions that I asked at
the beginning or partial answer to it
yes like Jo and I don't I don't have the
solutions but one important lesson I
think that we should keep in mind is
that in terms of the relationship
between prediction and health equity or
health inequity it is structural racism
not race that is the risk that our
technological design should engage with
in order to help us to envision an
equitable future that doesn't replicate
the past Thanks
I could not have predicted alphabetical
order we'll have a short break and then
come back